XCOM 2 hasn't even been out for a full  day but the crazy mods are already  pouring in if you're a dog person you're  in for a treat with the acord 47 an  assault rifle that looks like a puppy  developer fire axis is already promoting  the main gmod on Twitter the egg cord  can be downloaded from the Steam  Workshop creator John Terp says the  original plan was to replace the in-game  drone with the dog but it became much  easier to simply swap it in for a gun he  plans to update the mod in the near  future the a korg 47 isn't the only  major mod out there the team behind the  long war mod for the first game worked  with fire access to release three more  day 1 mods we gave XCOM to a 9 out of 10  so stuff like this can only make the  game better and if it's more XCOM 2 news  you're looking for you're already in the  right place